so
democrats
not great last night not great bob
at all so democrats went down to flaming
ferocious defeat in virginia it was just
a bloodbath a brutal sickening bloodbath
and it very upsetting it just did i am
so i'm just all broken up about it this
morning now remember joe biden had
predicted massive victory while he was
in glasgow yesterday it turns out that
joe biden couldn't be woken up to
deliver the actual bad news this morning
but but here he was yesterday trying to
trying to say that everything was going
to go great in virginia last night it
did not go great in virginia spoiler
alert
we're going to win
i think we're going to win in virginia
and you know you're reporting it being
close
the race is very close
it's about who shows up who turns out
and granted i did win by a large margin
but the point of the matter is that i
think that this is this is going to be
we all knew from the beginning it's
going to be a tight race
okay we didn't all know that from the
beginning if you look at the polls glenn
young was down like double digits at the
beginning of this race and then he won
last night by a fairly solid margin
according to the new york times
republicans claimed the governorship of
virginia for the first time in more than
a decade on wednesday electing a
businessman glenn younkin and presenting
their party with a formula for how to
exploit president biden's
vulnerabilities and evade the shadow of
donald trump in democratic leaning
states youngkin 54 a wealthy former
private equity executive making his
first run for office elevated education
and taxes while projecting a suburban
dad demeanor to demonstrate he was
different from trump without saying so
outright he defeated former governor
terry mcauliffe a democrat who with
trump out of office struggled to
generate enthusiasm among liberals at a
moment when conservatives are energized
in opposition to mr biden this race was
called pretty much off the bat by fairly
early last night people knew that young
kin was going to win and it wasn't just
that republicans won with junkin at the
top of the ticket they also won
lieutenant governor's race in virginia
they won the attorney general's race in
virginia
and in fact
they elected the first black female
lieutenant governor in the history of
the state of virginia
i believe the first hispanic a.g in the
history of the state of virginia which
means as we'll see that the republicans
again demonstrating their vicious brutal
white supremacy in the oddest of ways by
electing a very diverse slate of
candidates to higher office
meanwhile by the way
over in new jersey in new jersey it is a
dead heat right now between the
republican gubernatorial candidate jack
citarelli who no one knew who he was or
knows who he is today against phil
murphy who is the widely touted governor
of new jersey it was captain covet over
there he locked it down pretty much
everything and he was supposed to run
away with that race the polls showed
that he was up by near double digits not
like months ago like mcauliffe was then
the race titan he was up double digits
pretty much a week ago he was up eight
in the real clear politics polling
average yesterday and now
that race is so deadlocked it's gonna go
to recount
according to the new york times no less
bracing for democrats was a second
gubernatorial election unfolding in new
jersey the incumbent governor philip
murphy was narrowly trailing a
relatively obscure republican challenger
jack citarelli deep into the night a
mainstream liberal with ties to the
white house murphy was staking his hopes
for a comeback on a strong performance
in several solidly democratic areas
where votes were slow to report again
about 98 of the vote in at this point
and it's pretty much dead heat
the unexpected closeness of the race
underscored the overall vulnerability of
the democratic party much like mr yonkin
in virginia mr siatarelli appeared to
benefit from robust turnout in rural and
conservative leaning areas of the state
while making inroads in denser areas
such as bergen county the populist
suburb of new york city
unlike younkin shadorelli a former state
legislator had no
vast personal fortune to spend on his
candidacy national republicans looked at
his campaign as an extreme long shot
even if murphy were to prevail it's
going to be by am i my newt fraction
remember joe biden won the state of new
jersey by 16 points 16 points joe biden
won the state of virginia by 10 points
brutal brutal so youngkin in virginia he
said today we are going to change the
trajectory of this commonwealth
meanwhile mcauliffe refused to concede
as of late last night instead he just
went out and did like a weird little
dance he was very very strange
bottom line is terrible news in virginia
for the democratic party
and if you look at the internals on the
poll numbers they're just
i mean horrifying for the democrats
loudoun county right that is a
democratic county there was a 19-point
swing to the gop in loudoun county and
here i must give a shout out to the
daily wire zone reporter lou grossian
who's been doing unbelievable reporting
from on the ground in loudoun county and
he is the person who uncovered this
massive scandal wherein the school board
of loudoun county was essentially
covering up the rape of a student in
their bathroom while promoting a
transgender bathroom bill
and turns out there are all sorts of
other
issues with malfeasance by the school
board in that district
and that county swung 19 percentage
points toward republicans in this
election cycle so investigative
reporting matters you should head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code real news to get 25 off honestly
support our investigative reporting
efforts they really do make a difference
also shout out to christopher ruffo who
did an unbelievable job covering
critical race theory across the country
as well specifically in virginia as
we'll see democrats their plan is just
to deny that they are radical at all and
then to call everyone who notices a
racist a 19-point swing in loudoun
county
also mcauliffe according to sahil kapoor
who's a national political reporter at
nbc news mcauliffe the democrat he ran a
bit ahead of biden among the non-white
voters in virginia he ran ahead of biden
among those voters he got absolutely
clocked by white women
in 2020 white women went for biden 50 to
49.
it wasn't a bigger margin because a lot
of rural and non-college-educated white
women went for trump so it was 50 to 49
for biden in virginia in 2020
virginia 2021
youngkin 57
mcauliffe 43 that is a 15 point swing to
the gop with that group that is
particularly among white women who are
non-college graduates
in 2020 56 of white women who are
non-college graduates went for trump 44
went to biden
okay so that was a split in favor of
trump but
a lot evener than last night last night
75 for yonkin 25 from a call-off among
white women or non-college-educated
okay what does that say it says that
when you have someone who is not quite
as offensive at the top of a particular
ticket that you can win back all of
those suburban white women you can hold
the trump coalition which is what young
kin did he didn't crap on trump he
didn't spend the campaign crapping on
trump instead he said he appreciated a
lot of things about trump but he also
didn't humor a lot of trump's more
absurd contentions and then he made the
issues not about trump he just avoided
making the election about trump and he
swamped terry mcauliffe particularly
with white women back to some of these
exit polling numbers just brutal for the
democrats on the economy and jobs 35
percent of voters in the virginia
election said that was their top issue
the economy and jobs young kin won that
group 63 to 36
okay on the issue of education which was
the number three issue among these exit
voters 15 people said it was their
number one issue
71 one for yonkin 71-29
okay that is luke's reporting that is
chris ruffo's reporting that is people
who are pointing out what exactly is
being taught to your kids in schools
that is not a virginia issue by the way
that is a national issue and if
republicans don't hold on to that if
they don't point out i've been saying
this literally since i began my career
the indoctrination of children in public
schools is a disaster area for the
country if republicans run on the
curriculum they're going to win because
parents don't actually know what kids
are being taught okay so on the economy
and jobs jungkin outpaces mcauliffe
63-36 on education he outpaces mccall of
71-29
on coronavirus mcauliffe wins 78-22 but
no one cares about that anymore because
basically this is all over among people
who said racism was their number one
issue unsurprisingly mcauliffe won 84-15
on abortion only five percent of people
said it was their top issue but 56 of
those people actually voted for yunkan
so all of the anti-choice he's an
anti-choice radical who's gonna stop
abortion that actually cut in yonkin's
favor on immigration 94 to five in favor
of yonkin and so you can see exactly why
young can won right here
how bad were the exit polls for
democrats here
okay i'm gonna go by by
group here okay so among 18 to 44 men
young can young kin was competitive he
only lost him a call of 52 to 47
among men aged 45 plus 58 to 42 for
young kin
among latinos and hispanics
in virginia youngkin won outright 54 to
45. he also won 13 of the black vote and
of the white vote devastating numbers
for the democrats plus as nate cohen
points out over the new york times
biden has nearly the worst approval
ratings of any president on record at
this stage of his presidency the worst
approval ratings of any president on
record at this stage of his presidency
okay so a few takeaways right here okay
number one it turns out that telling
your voters to vote is actually a better
strategy than telling your voters not to
vote republicans in those georgia senate
races at the beginning of this year they
basically told their voters your vote
doesn't matter and then people didn't
show up and then republicans lost in
what is a red state
okay virginia is a very blue state and a
republican said you should show up and
you should vote and your vote counts
and whether or not you are concerned
about voter fraud the best way to win is
to go and vote and focusing in on
are they going to steal it is it going
to be stolen is your voting account is a
bad way of running an election cycle is
a bad idea moving forward okay point
number two run against the democrats as
always run against the democrats make
the democrats your opponent i said this
throughout 2020 if people had thought
that joe biden was the issue joe biden
would have lost they didn't they thought
trump was the issue and so trump lost in
virginia people thought terry mcauliffe
and the democrats were the issue so
young can won it's that simple if the
election is about your opponent your
opponent loses tara makov tried to do
that to yunkan and he completely failed
because junkin is inoffensive youngkin
does not make people feel uncomfortable
youngkin makes it very youngkin did what
good candidates do he made it very
difficult to vote for his opponent he
made it very easy to vote for him
that is what good candidates do
bad candidates make it easy to vote for
your opponent and difficult to vote for
you that's what a bad candidate does
that's what terry mcauliffe did he went
out there like a fool and he said
parents should not be in control of
their children's education and then he
kept doubling down on that while
campaigning with randy weingarten he
kept telling parents that they are
racist if they mention the phrase
critical race theory he kept saying over
and over and over again that parents
should not determine whether or not they
are indoctrinated their kids are
indoctrinated with lgbtq propaganda in
schools that's up to the school boards
right that is it he made it very
difficult for people to vote for him and
he made it very easy for people to vote
for yonkin because he guess he he just
kept shouting that junkin was a racist
trumpkin
they kept saying it over and over and it
just didn't wash because youngkin isn't
and so young can won
these these are major lessons that
republicans need to take for the future
if they hope to continue winning also
further lessons republicans should not
shy away from the culture wars so i know
that there's the smart set in republican
politics who are constantly saying that
the culture wars are a dummies it's a
dummy's game why are you arguing on
culture the answer is culture motivates
people culture gets people up in the
morning
you know how your kids are educated in
schools matters a lot more to people
than their marginal tax rate i care a
hell of a lot about my marginal tax rate
it makes a big difference in my life but
i can tell you how my kids are educated
in school matters one million times more
than that
when republicans abandon the social
issues when they pretend the social
issues don't matter or they are a
distraction from the main issues this is
sort of how romney ran his campaign in
2012. they lose
romney did not run against barack
obama's radicalism in 2012. he ran
against his economic plan that is not
how you win the way that you win is by
pointing out the social radicalism of
your political opponents
and presenting a good economic plan
which is what young kin did
also this race made clear that
republicans can indeed keep together the
trump coalition and they don't have to
have all of the bad tweets to go along
with it
kirsten soltis anderson who's a pollster
for the washington she has a piece for
the washington examiner she points out
youngkin got all the upside of trump but
none of the downside
she says there's little doubt trump will
try to take credit for young's victory
to be clear trump quite literally phoned
it in at the last minute for young kin
after enough polls showed victory was in
sight young kin and trump did not donate
to each other youngkins had the bare
minimum about trump necessary to survive
the primary process
what trump did do over the last five
years was engage many formerly
disconnected voters and turn them into
more habitual voters for the gop so that
was good what trump did
he he continues to have an impact on
politics by turning out to vote in rural
areas just by having activated people
who are now used to voting that's a big
thing young can savvy move was not to
embrace trump but also not to insult
trump or disavow him he was not about
being pro or anti-trump he was about not
being trump he was about being young kin
hey and biggest lesson of all right now
republicans have a target rich
environment the democrats are an
absolute mess they're a mess
joe biden is a disaster area and again
it wasn't just in virginia it's all over
the country it's all over the country
and to give you some results from other
areas of the country that really cut
against the democratic party 2022 is
looking like an absolute wipeout for the
democrats
i would not be surprised if republicans
pick up 40 to 50 seats in the house
i certainly would not be surprised in
this environment if democrats lose the
senate outright
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed